estamos en la entrada de siloé en cali
donde el lunes se vivió una jornada de
auténtico terror para destacar que así
lo han denunciado los vecinos que
aseguran que ha habido muchos muertos
por herida de bala por parte de las
autoridades policiales cabe destacar
también que esclarecer en estos momentos
en colombia y en siloé concretamente en
la noche del lunes los muertos que ha
habido es muy complicado las
organizaciones humanitarias están dando
diferentes datos puesto que la situación
es de gran incerteza en todo el país
incluso estas denuncias de abuso
policial han llegado a la comunidad
internacional y especialmente después de
que un convoy humanitario fuese atacado
por parte de la policía por otra parte
nosotros nuestro equipo de france24
también estuvo en un punto caliente de
la jornada de protestas del lunes y lo
que pudimos ver es una un clima que
parecía prácticamente bélico por otro
lado para reconducir la situación el
alcalde jorge iván ospina el alcalde de
cali ha convocado una mesa social de
diálogo para tratar de devolver la
normalidad sin embargo también han
abierto corredores humanitarios para que
puedan entrar alimento
y gasolina y también medicamentos pero
sin embargo parece que esta situación no
va acabar aquí ya que el miércoles 5 de
mayo está convocado una nueva jornada de
paro nacional en toda colombia